[Music]
without objection under the previous
order the leadership
time is reserved morning business is
closed
under the previous order the senate will
proceed to executive session to consider
the following nomination
which the clerk will report
nomination department of veterans
affairs
dennis richard mcdonough of maryland to
be secretary
madam president senator from iowa
in his inaugural address
president biden said his whole soul
quote unquote was in the cause of
quote bringing america together uniting
our people
and uniting our nation end of quote
very worthy things to speak and
especially an
inaugural address he also recognized
that americans have serious
disagreements
everyone knows that our country is
deeply
divided politically i know from his time
in the senate that president biden
understands that people of good will can
have honest disagreements
about policy so he knows that unity does
not mean dropping
deeply held beliefs and accepting
his own policy agenda
as he said and i have two quotes here
every disagreement doesn't have to be a
cause of total war
and disagreement must not lead to
disunion
real unity requires
rediscovering what binds us together
as americans even when we have strongly
disagreed politically
as i have often said our nation is
unique in human history
in that it was founded not on the basis
of
common ethnic identity or loyalty
to let's say a monarch but on certain
enduring principles those principles are
best articulated in
simple but elegant words of the
declaration of independence
and you all read these regularly i'm
sure
quote we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all men are created equal that
they're endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights
among these are life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
end of quote it is a common commitment
to this ideal that has bound us together
as americans
from the beginning our patriotic
our patriot forefathers concluded
that these principles were worth
fighting for
and took up arms in an improbable quest
to defeat the largest and best trained
military
at that particular time this included
many
black patriots who fought for american
independence
a unifying fact that i believe deserves
a monument on the national mall
something that i've been working for
for years now i want to quote
margaret thatcher she once observed this
a fairly long quote so bear with me
americans and europeans alike
sometimes forget how unique is the
united states of america
no other nation has been created so
swiftly and successfully
no other nation has been built upon an
idea
the idea of liberty no other nation
has so successfully combined
people of different races and nations
within a single culture
both the founding fathers of the united
states
and successive waves of immigrants
to your country were determined to
create
a new identity whether in flight from
persecution or from poverty
the huddled masses have with few
exceptions
welcomed american values the american
way of life and american opportunities
and america herself has bound them
to her with powerful bonds of patriotism
and pride
the european nations thatcher continues
are not and can never be like this
they are the product of history not
of philosophy end of thatcher's quote
this quote from a british leader
is one of the best summaries that i have
read
about americans exceptionalism
the term american exceptionalism is
often misunderstood
be perhaps due to a quirk of the
english language miriam webster's
dictionary gives three definitions of
exceptional one
forming an exception like as they give
an example
rare an exceptional number of rainy days
or two better than average
superior exceptional skill is the words
they expand on
average deviating from the norm
such as having above or below average
intelligence
or physical dis disability
many people here and abroad assume
that those who talk about american
exceptionalism
are just using the second definition
and simply asserting that the united
states is better
than any other country and that is a
wrong
interpretation american sectionalism
an assertion of the plain fact
that america's foundation is very
different
from that of most other nations
however our foundation is increasingly
under attack
from both the right and the left
both the 19 16 19
project and white nationalists
assert that america's founding
principles
are a lie and that the united states was
founded
along ethnic lines
oddly enough this was the position
taken by john c calhoun in the united
states senate when he
articulated an alternative to the
founding principles
intending to justify maintaining
slavery in perpetuity
unfortunately abraham lincoln who
revered
the declaration of independence
prevailed
the notion that our founding principles
are a lie
isn't just bad history it breaks the
bonds that unite
americans of all backgrounds
the 1776 commission was established
specifically
to quote enable a rising generation to
understand the history
and principles of the founding of the
united states
in 1770 and to strive to form a more
perfect union
end of quote the introduction to the
1776 report states that
quote a rediscovery
of our shared identity rooted in our
founding principles
is the path to a renewed american unity
and a confidence in american future
i end the quote i could not agree more
that is why i was disappointed to see
president biden terminate this
commission
the same day he took office after making
his
call for unity the call to unity is
exactly
what the president asked for
in his inaugural address what
specifically in that 1776
commission document does president biden
disagree with yes
the report is critical
of far-left efforts to denigrate our
founding principles
but it is also an important corrective
to the alt-right effort to import
european-style's ethno-nationalism
which is also deeply on american in
every sense
the 1776 report calls for
quote a restoration
of american education which can only be
grounded
on a history of those principles that
is accurate honest unifying inspiring
and ennobling and quote
by contrast california has proposed
an ethnic study curriculum
that is rooted in the fundamental
divisive tendency
of critical race theory which
with its focusing on separate groups of
americans
into different degrees of oppressor and
oppressed
interestingly despite the california
curriculums
focus on victims of prejudice
discussions of anti-semitism is omitted
in favor of criticism of israel
this curriculum also totally skips
over the life and work
of dr martin luther king jr
remember his dream so i quote that
statement that he made it is a dream
deeply
rooted in the american dream i have a
dream
that one day this nation will rise up
and live out the true meaning of its
creed
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal end of
quote
now that is a very unifying
statement i encourage all americans to
read the
1776 report for yourself
see if you don't agree with the central
message
that shared attachment
to our timeless founding principles is
what binds us
as a nation it is no longer
available on the main white house
white house website can still be found
on the trump administration's archive
website
it is also available on the hillsdale
college website i have another short
remark that i want to make on another
subject
12 years ago this past sunday
then vice president biden was in munich
germany
to deliver the obama administration's
first
major foreign policy speech to world
leaders
he said quote it is time
to press the reset button and to revisit
the many areas where we can
and should be working together with
russia
into quote the premise was
that the bush administration had been
too tough on russia
and a more conciliatory approach
conciliatory approach
was needed beyond the rhetoric
this involved abruptly scrapping
planned missile defense cooperation
with their allies the checks and the
polls on the anniversary
of the soviet invasion of poland
keep in mind this was six months
after russia had invaded and occupied
territory
of our ally the republic of georgia an
occupation that is still ongoing
this very day that all happened
a year after the publication of the book
entitled the new cold war
by edward lucas detailing the dangerous
nature of the putin regime
the russian reset was not just a failure
the reset was ill-conceived
and counterproductive from the start
putin's russia like the soviet union
before it
only understands strength
unilateral concessions actually
encourage
further aggression like we saw and still
see
with ukraine i appreciate
now president biden's more recent
tough talk on russia i like his
rhetoric better than many things that
president trump
said however i like
trump's actions like sanctions against
the nordstream pipeline
arming and training the ukrainian
military and pardoning with our
front-line
allies the biden administration no
longer talks of
a russian reset but it has already
announced
the extension of the one legacy
of the reset policy the new start treaty
with russia
gutted important monitoring and
verification measures
that were included in the predecessor
agreement
president reagan famously quoted a
russian proverb
trust but verify when he was negotiating
with mihail
gorbachev new start
cut out the verifying part leaving only
trust but surely
we've all learned by now that we cannot
trust
vladimir putin he has been caught
red-handed
violating other arms control treaties
so has recently happened extending the
new start treaty
without trying to improve it is a missed
opportunity i hope that president
biden's future actions more closely
match his words and he scraps all
vestiges
of the obama russian reset policy that
he announced
12 years ago this weekend
i yield the floor and i
i suggest the absence clerk will
call the world miss baldwin
you
you
and pro tem the majority leader
thank you mr president are we in a
quorum called yeah i ask unanimous
consent the quorum be dispensed with
with objection sorry now mr president
the senate is steadily confirming
members of president biden's cabinet
and other key administration officials
in a few hours we'll add one more to the
list when the senate confirms dennis
mcdonough
to serve as secretary of veterans
affairs under president obama
mr mcdonough was a member of the
national security council
and the white house chief of staff he
was a regular face at walter reed and a
frequent visitor of our troops deployed
abroad
the va has one of the most sacred
missions of all our agencies
deriving its motto from president
lincoln's second inaugural address
to care for those who who shall have
borne the battle
but the task of achieving that mission
is one of organization
institutional know-how and
administrative troubleshooting
i'm confident that mr mcdonough's
decades of experience at the highest
levels of government
make him well qualified to take on the
job
even as senators prepare this week to
sit as a court of impeachment
the senate will continue its work on
other responsibilities
committees will continue to process
nominations
including the committees the nominees to
lead the epa the department of commerce
department of labor in the office of
management and budget
at the same time committees will
continue pressing the work of addressing
the covit crisis
last week in the early hours of friday
morning
the senate passed a budget resolution
that will pave the way for president
biden's american
rescue plan as promised
the senate held an open bipartisan and
vigorous amendment process
several bipartisan amendments passed
with overwhelming majorities and were
added to the resolution
the fact that the debate went all night
and only concluded
at around 5 30 in the morning is a
testament to the vigor
of the amendment process which again i
know
was bipartisan the first amendment in
fact a very important one
by the senator from arizona ms cinema
and the senator from mississippi mr
wicker
helped our restaurant industry and it
was bipartisan
now our senate committees have
instructions to begin crafting
legislation to rescue our country from
covet 19
to speed vaccination distribution
provide a lifeline to small businesses
help schools reopen safely save the jobs
of teachers
firefighters and other public employees
and support every american
who is struggling to put food on the
table and keep a roof
over their heads this important
historic work will give
hundreds of millions of americans the
relief they need
while getting our country back to normal
as quickly
as possible now on impeachment
tomorrow the second impeachment trial
of donald j trump will commence only the
fourth trial of a president or former
president
in american history and the first trial
for any public official that has been
impeached
twice for the information of the senate
the republican leader and i in
consultation with both the house
managers and former president trump's
lawyers
have agreed to a bipartisan resolution
to govern the structure and timing of
the impending trial
let me say that again all parties have
agreed to a structure
that will ensure a fair and honest
senate impeachment trial
of the former president each side will
have ample time to make their arguments
16 hours over two days for the house
managers
the same for the former president's
council
if managers decide they want witnesses
there will be a vote on that
which is the option they requested in
regard to witnesses
the trial will also accommodate a
request
from the former president's council to
pause the trial during the sabbath
the trial will break on friday afternoon
before sundown
and will not resume until sunday
afternoon
as in previous trials there will be
equal time for senators questions
and for closing arguments and an
opportunity for the senate
to hold deliberations if it so chooses
and then we will vote on the article of
impeachment
and if the former president is convicted
we will proceed to a vote
on whether he is qualified to enjoy any
office
of honor trust or profit under the
united states
the structure we have agreed to is
eminently fair it will allow
for the trial to achieve its purpose
truth and accountability
that's what trials are designed to do to
to arrive at the truth of the matter and
render a verdict
and the and following the despicable
attack
on january the 6th there must there must
be truth and accountability
if we are going to move forward heal and
bring our country together once again
sweeping such something as momentous as
this under the rug
brings no healing whatsoever let's be
clear about that
now as the trial begins the forces
aligned with the former president
are prepared to argue that the trial
itself is unconstitutional
because donald trump is no longer in
office relying on a fringe legal theory
that has been roundly debunked by
constitutional scholars from across the
political spectrum
just yesterday another very prominent
conservative republican constitutional
lawyer
chuck cooper wrote in the wall street
journal
that republicans are dead wrong if they
think an impeachment trial of a former
president
is unconstitutional here's what he wrote
quote given that the constitution
permits the senate to impose the penalty
of permanent disqualification
only on former office holders
it defies logic to suggest that the
senate is prohibited from trying and
convicting
former office holders the senators
who supported mr paul's motion should
reconsider their view and judge the
former president's misconduct
on the merits that's no liberal
that's chuck cooper a lawyer who
represented house republicans in a
lawsuit against speaker
pelosi a former adviser to senator
cruz's
presidential campaign driving a stake
into the central argument we're going to
hear
from the former president's council
now i understand why this fringe
constitutional theory is being advanced
for the past few weeks the political
right has been searching for a safe
harbor
a way to oppose the conviction of donald
trump without passing judgment on his
conduct
to avoid alienating the former
president's supporters
without condoning his obviously
despicable
unpatriotic undemocratic
behavior but the truth is no such safe
harbor exists
the trial is clearly constitutional by
every frame of analysis
by constitutional text historical
practice senate precedent
and basic common sense
a president cannot simply resign to
avoid accountability for an impeachable
offense
nor can they escape judgment by waiting
until their final few weeks in office to
betray our country
the impeachment powers assigned to the
congress by the constitution
cannot be defeated by a president who
decides to run away
or trashes our democracy on the way out
the door
this trial will confirm that fact
the merits of the case against the
former president will be presented
and the former president's council will
mount a defense
ultimately senators will decide on the
one
true question at stake in this trial
is donald trump guilty of inciting a
violent mob
against the united states a mob
whose purpose was to interfere with the
constitutional process of counting
electoral votes
and ensuring a peaceful transfer
of power and if he is guilty
does someone who would commit such a
high crime against their own country
deserve to hold any office of honor or
trust
ever again consistent with the solemn
oath
we've all taken to do impartial justice
according to the constitution
and laws of the united states that
that is the question every senator
must answer in this trial i yield the
floor
so the quorum the clerk will call the
roll
ms baldwin
you
you
you
madam president leader
ask consent to further proceeds on the
quorum call be dispensed with
without objection first briefly madam
president i'm pleased that
leader schumer and i were able to reach
an agreement on a fair process
and estimated timeline for the upcoming
senate trial this structure has been
approved by both former president
trump's legal team
and the house managers because it
preserves
due process and the rights of both sides
it will give senators as jurors ample
time to review the case
and the arguments that each side
will present on a completely
different matter on saturday we lost a
great statesman and scholar
who gave more than 80 of his 100 years
to his country george schultz service
began in the u.s marine corps
from the beaches of peleliu he was among
the americans who helped retake the
pacific from japan back home he earned a
phd in economics
he taught at mit and would later helm
the university of chicago's graduate
business school but public service
beckoned
and george schultz began a decades-long
run
of ping-ponging prolific prolifically
between
academia and top government posts
the first of three presidents who'd
benefit from his expert counsel dwight
eisenhower hired him as a senior staff
economist
back in 1955.
a decade and a half later he was back
this time as president nixon's secretary
of labor
where he worked on desegregation and
later as
omb director then at a pivot
pivotal moment for the u.s and world
economies george schultz was tapped to
lead the treasury department
he fought inflation and worked to
modernize our monetary policy so
american leaders
could control america's destiny
after an interlude in the private sector
secretary schultz's country came calling
again
he spent six and a half of president
reagan's eight years as secretary of
state
he helped steer the smart and strong
foreign policy that clenched the free
world's victory
over the soviet union but even as the
reagan administration
nudged communism into a box canyon
this top diplomat's master touch was
vital in making sure that tensions
did not rise too high as amazing as it
sounds
this impressive resume doesn't fully
explain george schultz's incredible
reputation
it wasn't just all he did it was how he
did it
he led with awfulness fairness and above
all integrity he lived by the maximum he
shared
in his centennial reflection just a few
weeks ago
here's what he said trust is the coin
of the realm his honesty and
thoughtfulness one wide admiration that
transcended politics
he won the trust of career diplomats and
state department staff
including those who did not naturally
lean to the reagan right
famously when new ambassadors met with
him on their way abroad the secretary
would spin a globe and
ask them to point out their country the
unlucky ones who fell for the trap and
pointed to their foreign
destination were sliffly swiftly
corrected no he said your country
is always america
at the mcconnell center at the
university of louisville we host a
distinguished speaker series
george schultz honored us as the very
first ever
distinguished speaker back in 1993
and he kept right on writing and
speaking and mentoring young people
up until just a few weeks ago
america was his country all right he
loved it deeply
and served it always the senate's
prayers are with the schultz family and
all their friends and colleagues
he leaves behind a truly remarkable life
in 2020 a republican senate and
republican administration led
five historic pandemic rescue packages
on a completely bipartisan basis
we marshal the largest federal response
to any crisis since world war ii
about four trillion dollars across five
bills
all of it completely bipartisan
but now washington democrats have other
ideas even though we are still pushing
out 900 billion dollars in relief that
congress passed less than two months ago
even though a group of senate
republicans met with president biden to
discuss bipartisan avenues for hundreds
of billions of dollars more
washington democrats have decided they
want to go it alone
it was last march remember when a senior
house democrat called this disaster
quote a tremendous opportunity to
restructure things to fit our vision
americans are suffering but their side
seems to see an opportunity to ram
through
ideological change that's the impulse
behind democrats latest 1.9 trillion
dollar proposal
their plan for more massive borrowing
puts left-wing myths
ahead of scientific evidence and the
nation's
urgent needs while the biden
administration's own scientists say
schools
could reopen safely right now with smart
and simple precautions
their proposal buys into the myth from
big labor that schools should stay shut
a whole lot longer while republicans
want to save as many jobs as possible
washington democrats are backing senator
sanders demand to move
to double the minimum wage the
congressional budget office says this
would kill 1.4
million american jobs nonpartisan
experts say it would send more people to
the unemployment line
than it would lift out of poverty but
remember
this is all about liberal dreams not
urgent needs some democrats even want to
break senate rules
to jam this through last week the senate
had a 14-hour voting marathon
on amendments to the phony partisan
budget the democrats jammed through
as a procedural first step
we got senators on record on a host of
questions that matter to american
families
sadly democrats blocked our efforts to
say that at the very least
the very least school districts where
teachers have been vaccinated certainly
need
to reopen to press states to accurately
report nursing home deaths
to protect the free exercise of religion
and several more
other amendments divided democrats and
were adopted for example over some
democrats objection the senate said
illegal
immigrants should not receive stimulus
checks
that the keystone xl pipeline should not
be canceled
and that our government should not
declare war
on fracking but amazingly enough at the
end of the night
the very same senate democrats who
sought to appear moderate by supporting
these three things turned around and
voted in lockstep
to strip them all out again our
colleagues who said they supported these
changes voted to strip
them right back out at the end
of the evening that's about as
washington d.c
as it gets for the sake of america's
kids america's jobs americans health
democrats should put the political games
aside and resume the same kinds of
bipartisan talks
they demanded constantly all of last
year
american families deserve a process and
a bill
that puts their actual needs at the
center
now madam president on one final matter
over the weekend hundreds of thousands
of protesters
stood up across burma in defiance
of the military coup for a week now the
military has detained
hundreds of civil society leaders and
democratic elected officials
some on mysterious or obviously species
charges and others without any charge
at all their actions were illegitimate
right from the start and the treatment
of these political prisoners is showing
the world of the military regime's
disdain for the rule of law
in the face of this tyranny and with the
memory of how brutally the military has
dealt with protesters in the past
the public unity of so many of burma's
people
is a powerful display of courage
in far-flung cities and towns members of
the country's diverse ethnic groups
from the berman majority to the shan and
rohingya minorities
have rallied around the democratically
elected government
they are demanding justice and an end
to military rule i've been encouraged
over the past week by the diplomatic
efforts undertaken by the administration
to demonstrate the united states
condemnation
of the military's flagrant assault on
political rights
today it's time to follow up with
meaningful costs on those who aid and
abet
the suffocation of burmese democracy
the people of burma in the streets today
are putting their lives on the line
as one protester told the new york times
over the weekend
i don't care if they shoot because under
the military
our lives will be dead anyway
today these protesters are joining in
the same refrain heard repeatedly
in places like hong kong where
democratic progress is too often met
with shaq boots they're standing up for
basic freedoms
and they are paying close attention to
who
will stand with them
suggest health called rule
ms baldwin
you
you
you
madam president the senator from
nebraska i ask that the quorum call be
vitiated please
without objection thank you madam
president
i come to the floor today to discuss the
administration's decision
to extend the new start treaty by five
years
supporters hailed the move with the new
york times reporting
that the president's decision quote
avoided
a renewed arms race end quote
meanwhile critics who believed the
question of extension
had given the united states leverage to
extract
concessions from russia as well as china
described the move as a wasted
opportunity
and a giveaway to putin as the last
bilateral arms control agreement
between the united states and russia
perhaps it shouldn't be surprising
that the debate over extending new start
took on
outsize importance with parties on both
sides seeing it as the vehicle to
accomplish
all of their goals now with the
extension decided
it comes with an opportunity to regain
our perspective
and consider the way forward this begins
with a clear
understanding of what the new start
treaty accomplishes
and what it doesn't to begin with the
new start
treaty is not a panacea and extending
the agreement
does not prevent an arms race with just
the stroke of the pen
nor is it an unfair agreement that locks
in
russian advantages it is simply
an agreement between the united states
and
russia to limit some but not
all of the categories of nuclear arms
china is not a party to this agreement
as critics have pointed out the treaty's
counting rules
obscure the true number of deployed
nuclear weapons
and it has not prevented russia's
buildup of other kinds of nuclear arms
not covered by its limits
some have described these as loopholes
for russia
but they are well-known limitations that
also apply equally to both
sides since the treaty was signed
the united states has chosen not to
invest
in new nuclear weapons outside
of the treaty's limits well russia's
done the opposite
and they continue to expand their
nuclear arsenal
i disagree with my colleagues who see
that
as a failure of the treaty
it's a failure of the russian government
for continuing to build up its nuclear
arsenal
instead of matching our restraint and
lowering those
tensions but it would also be a failure
on our part if we had assumed russia
would refrain from building these
systems
out of the goodness of their heart
indeed russia's behavior since the new
start treaty was signed
reminds us that it continues to seek
a competitive advantage
and in order to achieve its goals it
will go around the limits
as it has done with the new start treaty
or to go straight through them as it did
with the inf treaty
so russia's nuclear capabilities
continue to expand
as does china's buildup of nuclear arms
that new start hasn't prevented these
from occurring
reflects the fact that the new start
treaty
simply does not account for the full
spectrum
of nuclear challenges and thus
with the agreement to extend the treaty
in place
serious threats still remain that really
demand our attention
the growth of both russia's and china's
arsenals
must be addressed some have called for
the biden administration
to immediately pursue talks to this end
while hurrying to convene another
diplomatic summit may have a reassuring
appearance just
to some diplomacy is
not an end unto itself it is a means
to an end and it is
important to remember that negotiating
limits on
russia's tactical weapons and bringing
china into the arms control process
have long been u.s diplomatic
objectives indeed the obama biden
administration
sought these goals as did the trump
administration
which deserves credit for elevating them
to the highest levels
however the consistent refusal
of both russia and china to engage in
serious talks demonstrates
that neither nation feels sufficient
incentive to negotiate
new attempts at negotiations without
addressing this
it wouldn't achieve a different result
in truth what's needed isn't
another conference in a european capital
it is a serious effort here at home
to create incentives for both russia and
china
to halt their nuclear buildups and to
have them choose a different path
congress and the administration should
work together
to strengthen the hands of our
negotiators
and to that end we can start by
rejecting calls
being made by some advocates to cut
our nuclear forces unilaterally
or allow them to age into obsolescence
by delaying their much needed
modernization
these calls aren't new however
our senior military leaders have
consistently advised against such
courses of action
and the past two administrations have
rejected them as well
they should be rejected again
as most in this chamber know our nuclear
forces
have aged far beyond their designed
lifetime after delaying and deferring
the modernization of our nuclear forces
for
decades we are now at an inflection
point
as admiral richard the current stratcom
commander testified last year quote
many of the modernization and
sustainment efforts necessary to ensure
the deterrence viability
have zero schedule margin and are late
to need
end quote his point is
clear further delay will result in
capabilities
aging out with no replacements available
our nuclear deterrent would literally
wither on the vine this would have a
number of disastrous consequences for
our security
at a time when nuclear threats are
growing
and it would also dramatically undermine
future diplomatic efforts
to negotiate limits with russia and
china
on their arsenals after all
why would either nation agree to new
rounds of arms reductions
if they knew that the united states was
cutting its forces anyway
regardless of whether they agreed to do
likewise
we must keep this in mind when we hear
calls
to dismantle the triad or cancel
our modernization programs
doing so would make our country
less safe by cutting the forces needed
to deter aggression
and it would make the world less safe
by ensuring that the united states
is never in a position again
to push for real reductions to russian
and chinese nuclear forces
instead of reducing incentives for
russia and china to negotiate
congress and the administration should
work together
to strengthen them and set the
conditions for
successful diplomatic efforts
in the future thank you madam president
i yield the floor i would suggest the
absence of
quorum rick will call the rule
ms baldwin
you
i'm president senator from minnesota
madam president are we in a quorum call
we are madam president i asked that the
quorum called the initiated
without objection madam president today
i rise
in support of my friend and fellow
minnesotan
dennis mcdonough as president biden's
nominee for
secretary of veterans affairs and no one
knows
about you the senator from illinois
madam president
about how important this job is for our
veterans
dennis grew up in stillwater minnesota
which is right near the wisconsin border
he is the grandson of irish immigrants
uh
the son of devout catholic parents and
brother to
10 siblings he attended saint john's
college
in collegeville minnesota and in
addition to
graduating summa [ __ ] laude he played
safety
on the very proud championship st john's
football team
i've been privileged to call dennis a
friend for years
and i know he will serve our country
well
as the secretary of veterans affairs
as he has done his whole life he will
honor the promises that our country
has made to our veterans and their
families
dennis's commitment to our nation's
veterans was clear during his time as
president obama's chief of staff where
he made sure that every decision
impacting our service members
veterans and their families was
befitting of their sacrifices
showing respect and gratitude for our
nation's veterans
is not something dennis just prioritizes
it's a value
for him as we know from his
time as president obama's chief of staff
he is an
adept manager who understands how to
tackle
complex challenges throughout our
government which will be
vital for the next secretary as we also
know the va
is facing a number of challenges from
helping veterans to stay
safe during the pandemic to improving
the quality of care for veterans around
the country
these are not simple problems and these
are not
simple challenges and they will require
as you have shown madam president
true leadership and vision which have
been again
the hallmark of dennis's time in public
service
i also know that he will work tirelessly
to find bipartisan solutions and i think
you see that
from the support that he has gotten
throughout the country
as well as on the veterans affairs
committee where i was honored to
introduce him
when he started on this journey of
senate approval
and it has never more been more
important than ever
to unite our country and get that kind
of support
so much of our work with the veterans is
about keeping our promises
and showing respect not just in words
but in action when other senators who
don't know
dennis as well are new to washington
what they may see as time goes on you
will see the qualities of honor and
loyalty
in dennis's commitment to his family
which also
includes his family in minnesota so i
know this firsthand
he has so many relatives that you can't
go anywhere without running into some
mcdonough
you see it in how he has treated
everyone he's worked with
when he worked in the senate when he
worked as president obama's chief of
staff
and i also will assure my fellow
senators that he will listen to senators
he will have respect to the people that
work here
you see it every day and how he always
puts his country first
during his distinguished career dennis
has approached each and every job
with the spirit of respect honesty and
collaboration
and a willingness to make himself
accessible to his colleagues and his
team
he is deeply committed to supporting the
workforce
at the va and i want our veterans to
know
he will do two things so well he will
listen
and he will get things done for you
one of my favorite stories about dennis
involves this
listening and then getting things done
we were having a lot of trouble up in
northern minnesota with the iron ore
mines closing down as you all remember
kind of coming out of the downturn it
never really bounced back and then we
had the steel dumping going on from
china
and other countries the illegal steel
dumping and that
really spread through the country and
led to the closure
of many of our mines and we tried we
introduced legislation
and finally i asked dennis to come up to
northern minnesota since he was from our
state
as president obama's chief of staff and
sit down
with a bunch of mayors from northern
minnesota from minnesota's iron range
with workers with mine owners and it was
this long long table
and nearly everyone had spoken and near
the end a miner named dan
hill he was the last to go and he said
well
everything's been said but so i'll just
tell the story
and he said that he was out of work and
he said that his
son had just graduated from preschool
and the teacher asked them at the
graduation what do you want to do when
you grow up
and kids were saying all kinds of things
that they wanted to
play basketball or they were going to
fly an airplane and
all kinds of cool things and dennis's
son looked at the teacher and he said
i want to be a minor like my daddy and
at that moment
dan hill took this steel worker
t-shirt that he had in his hands and he
threw it across the whole long table
and i remember sitting next to dennis
thinking you were a football player
catch the t-shirt and he caught the
t-shirt
and dan hill says mr mcdonough make it
come true
make it come true so dennis listen
but then he acted he went back to
washington
and he didn't just ignite a fire under
the commerce department
to get them to do even more work than
they were already doing
on enforcing tariffs and going after
this illegal dumping
and bringing things to the international
trade commission
but he also looked at other agencies and
he helped us along with sherrod brown
and so many others
to pass legislation that made a
difference and
all of this happened and dan hill got
his job back
and then i invited dan hill to come to
one of the
last state of the unions for president
obama
and dennis invited dan hill to the white
house and dan hill got to practically
meet everyone
surrounding the president that is
dennis mcdonough he listened but he
didn't just say oh i got there i went
we'll try our best he actually followed
through
through the minutia of government to get
things done i'm going to end with the
words of a poet who
president biden happens to love and
given dennis's irish roots i can't think
of a better person
to quote from today's uh from today's
vote
and it was mr haney who once wrote
anyone with gumption and a sharp mind
will take the measure of
two things what's said and what's done
so dennis will not just say words to the
veterans of this country as your
secretary
he will get things done with that madam
president i asked my colleagues
to support the nomination dennis
mcdonough
as secretary of veterans affairs thank
you and i yield the floor
absence of a quorum rick will call the
roll
this baldwin
you
president senator from south dakota oops
texas
at a president i ask unanimous consent
that the quorum call be dispensed with
without objection madam president it's
been more than a month
since a violent mob stormed this
building
and attempted to disrupt the
congressional certification of
presidential electors
the vote of those electors rather than a
peaceful transition
of power some of the mob turned their
grievances into violent action but again
that's the problem with mobs
no matter what the intentions were of
those who were simply exercising their
rights to free speech
and free assembly mobs invariably
degenerate
into the lowest common denominator
that element of the mob assaulted police
officers
destroyed property and trespassed in the
halls of the united states capital
some roamed these halls in search of
members for
of congress against whom they actually
threatened
harm and if not for the heroism of the
men and women of the capitol police
the human cost would have likely been
higher
the criminal acts of the mob were
disgraceful and
indefensible regardless of party or
politics there should be no disagreement
on that most basic
point the people making up this mob
came to washington with the idea that
the results of the 2020 election
were not final president trump
fed that fantasy by repeatedly claiming
the election was stolen
even after he had exhausted all of his
legal remedies
in dozens and dozens of lawsuits
the president's actions were reckless he
should have known better than to stoke a
flame he could not
and did not control
but the events of january the 6th are
only part of the story
and it is the congressional response
including impeachment that i now
want to talk about simply put the snap
impeachment
raises serious questions about
fundamental fairness
due process or more accurately the
lack thereof unlike previous
impeachments there was no formal inquiry
no investigation no hearings
no witnesses no cross-examination
no nothing we know impeachment is not
like a traditional
judicial proceeding it's not a court of
law
but it does make common sense and i
think this was the direction we gave the
house
during the last impeachment trial that
it's the house's obligation
to investigate develop the evidence and
then
charge not the other way around
historically this has been true for
impeachment proceedings each time the
house has conducted a full scale of
investigation
full-scale investigation before a vote
on the articles of impeachment
as i said that was the case last year
when the house spent months
deposing witnesses holding hearings
building a case against the president
before ever announcing
formal charges but this time around they
took an entirely different approach
in attempting to justify this
unprecedented departure from a fair
and dignified proceeding some of our
democratic friends claim that
no evidence needs to be presented
saying that we were all witnesses to
what happened on january the 6th
and that we can be jurors witnesses
and in the words of at least one
democratic senator victims
all at the same time this week
president trump's defense team will have
the opportunity to present its case
and i expect the lack of due process to
be a major
area of focus and rightfully so
unfortunately that's not the only
problem with this impeachment trial
the constitution requires the chief
justice of the united states supreme
court
to preside over the impeachment trial of
a president
but since this is the trial of a former
president
a private citizen someone who no longer
holds office
chief justice roberts will not be
presiding
as a result the senior senator from
vermont will now serve
as both a judge and a juror
in addition to being a witness i presume
and in the words of another senator a
victim
i respect senator leahy but the fact of
the matter is he cannot be an impartial
arbiter he has a conflict of interest
following the house's impeachment vote
senator leahy called president trump
the greatest threat to the constitution
and to american democracy in a
generation
he voted to convict donald trump during
the last impeachment trial and
apparently has already decided
to do it again in this trial
the fact of the matter is no american
let enough
let alone a former president should be
tried before a juror who's already
determined
guilt or innocence and who also serves
as a judge i want to be
abundantly clear though madam president
on one point
president trump's words and actions
leading up to the attack were reckless
and wrong but as we all know the
constitutional standard for impeachment
isn't
recklessness treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanors those are
the offenses that the
constitution allows congress to impeach
and remove a president from office for
violating
or from from from committing
which brings us to one of the biggest
concerns i have
donald trump is no longer president of
the united states
he's a private citizen our democratic
colleagues moved so fast that they could
impeach the president while he was in
office but failed to transmit the
articles to the senate
until he became a private citizen
legal experts have debated not only the
constitutionality of trying a former
president but also the wisdom
of doing so and i share concerns on both
those fronts
i think this ill-timed impeachment trial
sets a dangerous precedent for
future former presidents
as politicized as impeachment has come
become
it could become a reoccurring political
exercise that would be toxic
for our democracy prominent democrats
have warned about the dangers of using
impeachment as a political weapon
against an opposing party
during the impeachment inquiry of
president clinton
senator leahy himself counseled
a partisan impeachment cannot command
the respect of the american people
it's no more valid than a stolen
election
i agree with you the problem with one
party using impeachment to exact
political retribution on an opposing
party's president at the end of his term
or even after that president has left
office seems quite
obvious to me it's political retribution
depending on which party controls
congress and which occupies the white
house
this could turn into a regular blemish
on our democracy
rather than focusing together on our
future
in a new administration seeking common
ground and unity as president biden has
called for
such a precedent of trying a former
president
could create an endless feedback loop of
recrimination
i think this is a dangerous and
destructive path
and i would implore my colleagues on
both sides to consider the long-term
implications of this precedent
as justice story explained the framers
saw the senate as a tribunal
in his words removed from popular power
and passions
and from the more most more dangerous
influence of mere party spirit
and was guided by deep responsibility to
future times
so as before madam president i don't
think my role as a juror lightly
and i'll reserve final judgment until
both the house impeachment managers and
president trump's defense team
have had the opportunity to present
their cases
but i do think indeed i fear
we're skating on very thin ice and are
in danger of inflicting great harm to
our country
by this rushed unfair and partisan
proceeding may god help us
senator from tennessee thank you madam
president
when president biden addressed the
nation on inauguration day
he promised unity and bipartisanship
it was a big part of his inaugural
address and so far
the democrats here in washington are not
living up to that promise
their message and we saw this last week
is not unity it is submit
and conform on his very first day in
office
president biden rubber stamped 17
separate executive orders since then
he has approved so many changes that
a lot of tennesseans can barely keep
track of the orders and memos and
directives
that are flying out of the oval office
it's safe to say
the only benchmark they have to work
with
is the number of lost jobs
we'll see as a result of all of this
paper and pen governance and paperwork
jobs gone stroke of a pen
madam president the american people are
very unsettled by this
i'm hearing it from democrats
independents republicans
libertarians last week i came to the
floor and i spoke in detail about how
this
lack of clarity about the future
has made many tennesseans fearful
of the impending changes to our national
security policy
they are very unsettled so many of our
veterans in tennessee have talked with
me about this
they don't like all this soft talk when
it comes to
talking about china and russia and iran
and north korea
they're worried about what comes next
the domestic policy mandates have not
done nothing at all
to give reassurances or calm spirits
last week the senate democrats put forth
a budget
proposal that treats struggling
communities
like hypotheticals that could work with
theoretical changes all created for a
graduate
level economics exam
they're not dealing with real problems
in real life for about 15 hours
madam president we debated and voted on
a fraction
of the almost 900 amendments filed in an
attempt to do some damage control to
that budget resolution
but when friday morning came and went
all the democrats had to offer was a
glaringly partisan resolution that
blatantly contradicted
president biden's stated commitment to
unity and bipartisanship
and you know what in a perfect world
the solutions the democrats have come up
with
just might work but we do not live
in a perfect world we live in a
fallen world this
country is not created
in the image of the democratic party
to anyone who has ever managed a small
business budget
what my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle are trying to do
just does not make good common sense one
of the top
issues i hear about from people back
home in tennessee
is this proposal they have for a fifteen
dollar an hour
minimum wage i feel i should remind my
colleagues that
resistance to this mandate doesn't come
from a place of
stinginess or classist hatred
but from a place of absolute confidence
that it will destroy small businesses
even
with the phase in period i have not
heard from a single business owner
who will be able to pay the wage and
employ the same number of people
not one they'll have to let
staff go a report by the congressional
budget office
released just today echoes
and confirms their concerns
by 2025 the democrats proposal will cut
jobs for 1.4
million workers at a time madam
president
when workers are struggling to get back
to work
so much for job creation and we all know
the best
economic stimulus is a job
just six weeks ago congress passed a 900
billion dollar coveted relief
package very little of that money has
been spent and yet democrats and the
white house
continue to demand trillions
that's right trillions in
overbroad spending that targets no
specific
problem and has no actual
bipartisan support if that's not bad
enough
billions of dollars from last year's
bipartisan
relief packages all five of them also
remain unobligated
so we're 3.6 trillion dollars
in spending and
they're wanting another 1.9 trillion
dollars with little idea
of the effect that remaining unobligated
funding will have
on the economy but still the data shows
that what has been spent already has
made a difference and will continue
to do so relief should be timely
it should be targeted it should be
temporary
those that need the help should get the
help
but we do not need over-broad spending
the congressional budget office released
another report just over a week ago
showing
that if we leave the laws governing
how we tax and spend alone
leave them alone on the books in force
the gdp will continue to rise and the
economy will
get back to its pre-pandemic
health without without congress
authorizing one more penny in relief
spending so
the american people want to know why
why are the democrats claiming that the
only solution
to our present crisis is to spend as
much as possible
as quickly as possible without
considering
which sectors of the economy actually
need the help
which families need help which
individuals need help
what we do know is what we saw in 2009
and 10 and 11 and 12 and 13
and 14 and 15
is that if you get in here
and over spin without targeting without
direction
you slow you slow
the recovery we know that
we watched it we lived through it
they're going to need a better answer
than
because we say so because
this is what we're going to do because
the people understand that the federal
deficit
was historically large even before the
pandemic they know how debt works
and that a big deficit means more of
that federal
debt they also know that who holds that
debt
matters and that we're beholden
right now to china to opec
for trillions of dollars in that debt
scale that down for a minute when that
same thing happens
to one of these small businesses when
they max
their credit line if they fall behind
in their payroll they can't plan for the
future they can't plan for
emergencies and they can't invest
in their own success the same concepts
apply to the federal budget
you cannot tax and spend
your way to prosperity you have to have
economic growth so i ask my colleagues
why are you making
decisions that are going to slow the
recovery
and slow the economic growth
the democrats approach to planning for
the future
might sound good in theory it
might sound good in hypotheticals but
real life economics it's not it
future pandemics are not the need to
innovate and stay competitive in the war
fighting
domain is not those are
real life issues
the democrats have been so aggressive
this past couple of weeks and president
biden and taking out the eraser
and trying to erase four
years of productive policy
that benefited millions of americans
and the people are starting to wonder
what
else they're going to throw away in
favor
of a very autocratic authoritarian
empty vision for our nation i yield the
floor
senator from montana thank you madam
president madam president i have one
request for a committee to meet during
today's session of the senate
it has approval of the majority of
minority leaders
duly noted madam president i would ask
unanimous consent that
before i'd be able to finish my remarks
before the vote without objection
thank you madam president i rise today
in support of dennis mcdonough
dennis is president biden's choice lead
the department of veterans affairs
there though there is a great political
divide in our nation
i believe that veterans across the
country and members on both sides of the
aisle are united by a very basic
expectation
that the next va secretary be an
individual of honesty
integrity and vision this individual
must listen to veterans
and put their well-being above all else
dennis mcdonough has demonstrated that
he is unequivocally
the man for this job and to be clear
this is not an easy job
but dennis is used to making tough calls
he has shown an
exemplary commitment to public service
and a strong willingness to do right by
those
who have worn the uniform and sacrificed
on behalf of our liberties
his white house chief of staff he
quickly earned a reputation for getting
the job done
working across federal agencies and
finding
common ground for the last 20 years he's
played a key role in many decisions
surrounding sending our military men and
women to war
and knows that taking care of these
folks when they return home
is a cost of war and a shared
responsibility
veterans need someone like dennis
fighting in their corner
but the truth is there is simply too
much at stake
with more than 400 000 americans dying
from covet 19
in less than a year the va secretary's
top responsibility
will be ensuring that the department has
everything it needs
from vaccines to personal protective
equipment
to additional health care and supportive
services to care for veterans and
protect
the va's employees and he will be held
accountable
when it comes to swiftly implementing a
number of historic reforms
from the john scott hanan's veterans
mental health
improvement act a bill that is out of
box sinking to help our veterans
and the mental health challenges and
suicides that have resulted to the
deborah sampson act
and act to help the largest or the
fastest growing group of veterans
our women veterans have access to care
to the expansion of presumptive coverage
for thousands of additional vietnam
veterans
exposed agent orange in overdue
coverage for our vietnam veterans
not to mention a myriad of other
critical priorities that have been in
the works for years
and needs serious attention such as the
caregivers program
and the electronic health records
modernization effort
but dennis is fully prepared to take on
these responsibilities
he's ready to build the trust of our
nation's service members veterans and
their families
and treat them with the respect that
they have earned
now more than ever veterans need a
strong leader who will prioritize
delivering timely and quality health
care
and benefits over making political
points
i am confident that as va secretary
dennis will be squarely focused on
serving these needs
i asked my colleagues to join me today
in confirming him to this role
where i have no doubt that he will be
successful
our nation's veterans are counting on us
now unfortunately my friend and
colleague ranking member of the senate
veterans affairs committee jerry moran
couldn't make it back in time for this
nomination
due to bad weather and flight delays but
he was planning on voting to advance his
nomination today
because he believes dennis mcdonough is
someone who shares his commitment to
taking care of our veterans
i have jerry's statement here i would
ask unanimous consent
that it would be added to the record of
jackson
with that madam chair i yield and
suggest the absence of a quorum
no the question is on the nomination
is there a sufficient second there
appears to be
the clerk will call the roll this ball
went
mr barrasso mr bennett
mrs blackburn mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker
mr booker mr bozeman mr brawn
mr brown
mr burr miss cantwell
mrs cappateau
mr cardin mr carper
mr casey
mr cassidy
miss collins mr coons
mr cornyn ms cortez masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr danes
miss duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mrs gillibrand
mr graham
mr grassley
mr haggerty
miss hassan mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhale
mr johnson
mr kane mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
miss klobuchar
mr langford
mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
miss llamas
mr mansion
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran miss murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr risch
mr romney
miss rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby miss cinema
miss smith
miss davenau mr sullivan
mr tester mr
thune mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tuberville
mr van hollen mr warner
mr warnock ms warren
mr whitehouse mr
wicker mr wyden
mr young
you
you
senator is voting in the affirmative
baldwin blackburn cantwell carper
coons cramer crapo duckworth
feinstein hassan leahy lummus
murray peters reed sanders
cinema smith tester white house
senators voting in the negative cotton
holly marshall
mr bennett mr bennett
i mr luhan mr lujan
[Music]
aye
mr tuberville mr tuberville
aye mrs gillibrand mrs gillibrand
i mr sass mr sass
i
mr dia mr padilla aye
mr rono mr rono aye
mr ossoff mr ossoff i
miss collins miss collins i
mr van hollen i mr rounds mr rounds
i
pick and looper mr hickenlooper
aye mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith
aye
miss cortez masto miss cortes masto
i
you
mr heinrich mr heinrich i
mr king mr king i
mr scott mr scott of south carolina aye
mr casey mr casey i
mr kane mr kane aye
mr bozeman mr boseman i
mr shelby mr shelby aye mr warnock mr
warnock
aye
you
mrs shaheen mrs shaheen i
mr romney mr romney i
mr rish mr resh i
mr schumer mr schumer aye mr leahy
mr leahy aye mr wind
mr wyden i
mr mr kelly i
mr brown mr brown aye
mr durbin mr durbin i
mr cardin mr cardin aye
mr sullivan mr sullivan i
mr lee mr lee aye
mr hovind mr hovind i
mr menendez mr menendez
i joggerty mr hagerty
no mr lankford mr lankford
aye ms rosen miss rosen
hi
mr cornyn mr cornyn i
mr merkley mr merkley i
mr booker mr booker i
miss ernst miss ernst no
miss domino miss dubbing out
i
mr wicker mr wicker i
mr young mr young aye
mr portman mr portman
i mr blunt
mr blunt aye mr sharks mr schatz
aye ms klobuchar miss klobuchar
aye mr warner mr warner
i
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell i
mrs cappato mrs capito
i mrs fisher mrs fisher
aye mr grassley mr grassley
aye mr scott mr scott of florida
no
mr johnson mr johnson
i mr braun
mr braun
cassidy mr cassidy i
miss murkowski miss murkowski i
mr murphy mr murphy i
mr danes mr james i
mr marquis mr markey aye
mr thune mr dune aye
ms warren miss warren aye
you
you
mr kennedy mr kennedy i
mr mansion mr mansion aye
you
mr graham mr graham i
mr rubio mr rubio
i
you
you
uh
mr tillis mr tillis
i
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
mr cruz mr cruz no
you
on this vote the yeaser 87 the nays are
seven
the nomination is confirmed under the
previous order the motion to reconsider
is considered made and laid upon the
table
and the president will be immediately
notified of the senate's actions
mr president the senator from ohio
president i ask unanimous consent the
senate proceed to legislative session
and be in a period of morning business
with senators permitted to speak
therein for up to 10 minutes each
without objection
thank you mr president
senator from ohio thank you president
today
amazon workers in alabama will begin
receiving ballots that will give them
finally a real voice in their workplace
by choosing choosing to join a union
amazon would not be the massively
successful company that it is jeff bezos
wouldn't be a multi-billionaire
without the hard work and the dedication
of its hundreds
hundreds of thousands of u s workers
they put in long hours they risk their
own health during this pandemic
to meet the increased demand that we all
know as of
october 20 000. think of this twenty
thousand amazon workers twenty thousand
workers
that one company amazon had contracted
cobia nineteen
that's as of october we know those
numbers would be
much higher today because of their hard
work
amazon's profits have soared by more
than 70
the company's workers deserve to share
in the success
that they made possible amazon claims to
recognize the value of its workers
they call their workers quote heroes
fighting for their communities
and helping people get critical items
they need
heroes they called them if the company
truly believed and appreciated that they
were heroes
amazon might come back with word but we
might back up its words with action
that means letting these workers
organize it means stopping the corporate
union busting tactics that they've
deployed against these workers
amazon one of the most most one of the
most powerful corporations in the world
unleashed all of that power to fight
their own own workers
who are just asking for a voice on the
job
they've harassed employees with
anti-union propaganda
misleading text messages websites flyers
one washington post headline really said
it all
amazon's anti-union blitz stocks alabama
warehouse workers
everywhere even the bathroom
workers have reported they don't get
enough time for bathroom breaks in the
warehouse
that's how intense the company's
pressure is when they're able to use the
restroom even there
workers are hit with anti-union
propaganda flyers
on the stall doors amazon has repeatedly
tried to block mail and voting
in force workers to hold the union
election in person
putting its workers remember twenty
thousand already been diagnosed
back in october putting its workers
health at even more risk
just to suppress the vote it's all part
of a pattern for amazon
in 2019 amazon fired a staten island
warehouse worker who called for
unionization
they monitor employees online
communications last fall
we learned the company plan to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars on new
software
to monitor their words threats like
unions
it's little wonder amazon is afraid of
workers getting more power
so much of their business model is built
on top of exploiting workers often black
and brown workers and women
instead of employing many drivers
directly they use what they call
amazon flex drivers just like with other
gig economy jobs flex
is corporate pr speak for denying
workers their rights
as full employees they failed to provide
complete data on covert 19 spread in the
workplace
so we really can't find out whether the
company is protecting its workers health
amazon rolled back its tiny two dollar
per hour pandemic raise in june
and it announced a two dollar an hour
bonus
pandemic raise with great fanfare uh
money months ago then they rolled it
back in june
and then they announced a one-time bonus
of 300
per worker not 3 000 per worker 300
a worker from a company that brought in
200 billion
in revenue the previous year 200 200 i'm
sorry 280 billion 280
000 million 280 billion dollars in
revenue
they gave workers a bonus of 300
and amazon's not alone the washington
post looked at the 50 biggest
corporations
and found between april and september
these companies handed out
more than 240 billion dollars to their
stockholders
through stock buybacks and dividends
companies like that are making more and
more and more money
they're giving it back to executives and
stockholders in huge dividends and stock
buybacks
yet their workers their workers ex are
exposed to this
these these health hazards at work
exposed to this virus
they come home always anxious and scared
about infecting their families
the workers risk their own health often
at rock bottom wages
to make those companies so profitable if
even a global pandemic where america's
workers have been on front line
if even that will not get corporations
to rethink their business model
that treats workers as expendable then
we have to give workers more power in
the job
a grocery store worker said you know
they say told me they say i'm essential
but
really i feel expendable because they
don't pay me much and they don't protect
me in the job
so what do we do it should mean
collective bargaining it should meet
unions
that's why i joined senator murray and
many of my colleagues last week
to reintroduce to protecting the right
to organize
act the pro act it's a comprehensive
overall of our labor laws
protect workers right to stand together
and bargain for fair wages fair benefits
safer workplaces we know corporations
have attacked and undermined
worker protections for decades made it
harder and harder for workers
to even stand a chance in organizing a
union when they choose to
and look what's happened to our economy
as corporations take away workers power
productivity goes up corporate profits
soar executive compensation
explodes through the roof but wages stay
flat in the middle class shrinks
just go over that again corporate
profits workers
productivity goes up workers are working
harder and more efficiently
productivity is up corporate profits
soar executive compensation explodes
but wages stay flat and middle class
shrinks our bill would work to level the
playing field
finally give workers a fighting chance
against corporate union boxing tactics
like we see
right now today last week the week
before
and today at amazon it would strengthen
the punishment against companies
that violate workers rights to organize
in the companies that retaliate against
union organizers it would restore
fairness to an economy rigged against
workers by closing loopholes that allow
employers
to misclassify their employees as
supervisors and independent contracts
contractors so they don't have to live
under labor law
we can't in this country whether it's
whether it's in
in las cruces or in dayton we can't have
a strong
growing middle class without strong
unions union members earn
19 more on the average than similar
workers in non-union jobs
they have better health care they're
better able to save for retirement they
have more
predictable hours talk to amazon workers
about their hours
and they have more control over their
schedules and more economic security
in a time when this pandemic reveals so
much about inequality in our society
it's more vital than ever that we
empower all workers
it's not a coincidence that so many of
the workers at corporations like amazon
exploit whom they exploit are workers of
color
it's true at the amazon alabama facility
the retail
wholesale department store union
organizing in alabama
has made respect and dignity central to
its campaign
it comes back to the dignity of work
remember what dr king said
he said no labor no job is menial
unless you're not getting adequate wages
the president of the retail wholesale
department store union stuart applebaum
said
we see this as much as as much as a
civil rights struggle
as a as a labor struggle we know where
dr king was assassinated
and what he was doing he was fighting
for civil rights he was fighting for
worker rights
fighting for sanitation workers in
memphis some of the most exploited
workers in america
a union card is a ticket to the middle
class life we fight for economic justice
by making it available
to all workers we just need corporations
just just to get out of the way
let workers organize let workers take
control
over their careers and their futures
when you love this country mr president
you fight for the people who make it
work
whether it's in new mexico or ohio or
all over this country
that's what the amazon workers in
alabama are doing it's what unions have
done
throughout our history in this country
it's what we can do in the senate by
passing the pro
act president i i yield the floor
senator from florida i ask you nams
consent the senate proceed to the
consideration of senate resolution 42
submitted earlier today
the clerical report senate resolution 42
honoring the memories of the victims of
the senseless attack
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
on february 14
2018
without objection the senate will
proceed
i ask unanimous consent the resolution
be agreed to the preamble be agreed
to and that the motions to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection without objection
mr president like to thank my colleague
senator rubio for joining me to
introduce this resolution today
honoring the 17 victims of the census
attack
at marjory stoneman stoneman douglas
high school on february 14
2018. alicia alejif
aledif scott biegel martin duque aguiano
nicholas dwart aaron feis
jimmy guttenberg chris hixson
luke hoyer kara loren
gina maltato joaquin olivar
elena petty meadow pollock
helena ramsey ali shakhtar
carmen shintrap peter wang
i think of those innocent lives almost
every day lost too early in the tragic
shooting
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
in parkland florida
these individuals were sons daughters
parents and partners
they were educators athletes musicians
many of them just kids with a life full
of promise ahead of them
my heart breaks knowing they'll never
get to pursue their dreams
and that their families will always have
a piece of their heart missing
since that horrible day i've worked
closely with many of the victims
families to ensure no
child educator or family has to
experience
that again we passed the marjory
stoneman douglas high school public
safety act
while i was governor of florida to make
sure a state does everything in its
power
to prevent further tragedies now as a
u.s senator i'm fighting for
improvements on the federal level
including the luke and alex school
safety act
named ever luke hoyer and alex schachter
which builds on our work to keep schools
safe
and while we can't bring back these
lives lost that tragic day nearly three
years ago
i'll always work to honor those lost and
do everything in my power to protect our
students
and educators ensure they have a safe
environment to learn and succeed
now they yield the floor to my colleague
senator rubio
i thank the uh my colleague from florida
i
recall vividly that day on
february 14th 2018 started like
it does most days for people across the
country
take your children to school drop them
off and in this case some of them maybe
drove themselves and
within hours the lives of 17 families
had been changed forever it was a
horrible tragedy 17
students and faculty members who lost
their lives another 17 who were wounded
in the attack
and it shocked the country it was a
shocking because
they went
there are so many i can point to that
have made a difference
in their own way they've all sort of
focused on different aspects of what we
should be doing and
i just wanted to take a moment today to
recognize one individual max
schachter i know many of you have gotten
to know him here and
this this man works tirelessly he lost
his son alex on that day
but his commitment has actually produced
significant progress
thanks to his leadership and i must say
his leadership and i spoke to him again
last friday and he continues to work on
these issues and thanks to that
last year the federal government created
a federal clearinghouse on school safety
best practices a place that any district
any school can go to
and something is constantly being
updated that puts
an essential location the best practices
and offers
access to an array of resources for
schools across our nation that are
looking to protect their students
and this is important because in the
aftermath of this everyone was
trying to figure out what should we do
and there was no central place where you
could go to and find that out
and recently as as a my colleague from
florida just pointed out i along with
with my colleague from florida and
senator ron johnson we reintroduced
luke and alex safety school safety act
named after partially after his son max
which would make this clearinghouse
permanent it was put in place by the
agency but this would make it permanent
and i just think of parents like max
have poured so much of their own lives
into this work and continue to do so and
he's
he's always churning out new ideas we
spoke this
last friday about data that's now
available that a lot of people don't
even know is there
data that shows you which schools are
having suspensions which schools are
having fights or schools are having
arrests and violence
as a way of finding anomalies in the
data i mean he's constantly
not just become a subject matter expert
you know through this tragedy but is
constantly looking for improvements
that can be not just done in florida but
across the country and he's tireless
all across the country there's something
else we took that was successful in
florida
and that today we've reintroduced alongs
with senator reid and
senator king and and my colleague and
that is from florida and that is
reintroducing
the extreme risk protection order and
violence prevention act
to encourage uh the passing of these
laws that allow you to identify someone
who is a danger to themselves or others
go to a court
provide them due process and potentially
prevent a suicide
or or a senseless act like what we saw
on that day three years ago and and what
this bill would not mandate it but
but it would dedicate department of
justice funds to incentivize more states
to adopt similar measures it will
encourage
the rest of the country to follow the
lead in florida and to save lives we
know it's prevented suicides and we know
it's prevented potential attacks
in florida and in the states where it's
been implemented and we don't
we can't force more states to do it but
we can try to incentivize it
and so it's my hope and my prayer that
as we continue to work together
that we can achieve this and other
things so that no family so that no
community no state no one
will ever have to go through what the
incredible families
of of parkland endured
on that day and in the three years that
have followed and so today as
we remember the lives that were lost
let us pledge to honor them by
continuing to move forward towards safer
and more secure schools
and communities in our work here
mr president i yield the floor
president senator from illinois
mr president i was just noting that the
senate chamber has been rearranged
because tomorrow we commence the
impeachment trial the second impeachment
of donald trump in the center of the
well
is a podium and microphone where the
attorneys representing the house
managers who voted the
impeachment resolution will stand to
make their case
a few hours after we commence the trial
the president's defenders will have the
same opportunity
they'll be standing in a spot that is
literally
four or five feet away
from a location still
fresh in my mind it was there
right in the center of the aisle between
the majority
and minority leader of the senate on
january 6th
when two men appeared that i'd never
seen before in plain clothes and stood
in the center of the well
holding automatic weapons
it was just minutes after the vice
president had been removed
from the chair where you're sitting
whisked off the floor of the senate by
secret service i imagine he was pulled
off the floor
it wasn't a follow me mr vice president
they pulled him off the floor
that was at 2 15.
within a few minutes the mob which had
invaded the united states capital was on
the march
on its way toward this chamber where
most of us were sitting
sitting having dealt with our
constitutional responsibility of
counting the electoral vote
i remember when they interrupted the
quorum call they were
conducting for one of the capitol
policemen to stand before us and say
everyone stay in your seats
we're going to bring in all the staffers
are going to line the walls
we're going to lock all the doors this
will be the safe room in the capitol
couldn't have been more than 10 or 15
minutes later than the same policeman
said everybody out now
the mob had come through the capitol
through the rotunda
was now on the senate side of the
building within easy reach
of a hundred senators and so we filed
out the back door and down a staircase
over to the tunnels and down to the
heart building hoping
we'd escape them i watched through the
windows i went down
the steps and saw all of the flags
coming up
toward the capitol american flags trump
flags
flags i didn't recognize all the people
coming up here
we know what happened later that same
day
the mob crashed through the doors
into this chamber posed for pictures at
our desks and
scrawled messages to us went through our
desks and looked at him
literally interrupted the business of
the united states senate
accounting of the electoral votes
was that just an accident that thousands
of people
were in washington on january 6th
was that just an accident that they
gathered in the ellipsis for the
president of the united states donald
trump to speak to them
was it just an accident that within 40
minutes or 45 minutes
after the president sent them off to the
capitol they were here
breaking windows and breaking down doors
to come inside
no it was by design
we're now learning who designed that
strategy and that attack on the capitol
and tomorrow we're going to start a
trial to determine whether the president
of the united states of america
bears responsibility for inciting that
mob
for inspiring that insurrection when you
read the history
of the writing of our constitution
it's almost impossible maybe it is
impossible to put yourself in the moment
these men all men gathered in
philadelphia
had just fought a bloody long
war a revolutionary war against one of
the most powerful nations in the world
and they were setting up a government on
this side of the ocean
with the hopes that it would survive
and they were worried they were worried
about the enemy from without
and the enemy from within
and they talked about our responsibility
to maintain this democracy
and the challenges we might face
at the time they were wary because of
what they lived through
as we read about it now we wonder
what was the concern what was behind all
that concern
if you're honest you know that in 1861
our nation went to war with itself in a
civil war
with over a half a million lives lost
so it was a fragile democracy as they
thought
but we never dreamed at least i never
dreamed that in the 21st century
there would be a concern over an
insurrection
to overthrow the government of the
united states
with violence no not not in america
not in 2021
that's exactly what happened on january
6th
and that's why we're meeting tomorrow
for the accountability of
donald trump for that event now there
are people who have told us
we should get over it get over it he's
gone
why do you keep talking about donald
trump let him ride off into the sunset
as one fellow shouted at me at the
airport
a few weeks ago why would you want to
keep reminding us
of our differences and divisions
well i think the answer is pretty
obvious
we can't reach real unity in america
until we deal with the reality of
america as donald trump left it
and january 6 was a classic illustration
there's one other image i shared my
thinking about this trial
when i hear former u.n ambassador nikki
haley
the former governor of south carolina
say get over it to the democrats
i think of that solemn scene in the
capitol rotunda
last week as we honored capitol hill
policeman
brian siknik who was murdered by that
mob
murdered by that mob i spoke to his mom
and dad afterwards he always wanted to
be a police officer
he'd served in the air force but he
wanted to be a police officer
and his mom said we thought of all
places for him to be a police officer
the safest had to be the united states
capitol building
and she lost her son to that murderous
mob
i can't get over that i'm sure his
family will never get over it
and if we can't give an honest answer to
the american people
of what happened and who was responsible
for its shame on us
america came close to losing this
democracy on january 6th
for this president's design was to make
sure that election didn't count
that november third was ignored
what happened on january 6 was an
attempted coup
make no mistake as others have pointed
out
an attempted coup that is not punished
is a trial run for the next time
over the four years of his presidency
someone
decided to take account
of the many times that the president
lied to the american people
they were in the thousands many of his
lives were attempted to discredit anyone
or any institution that stood in his way
it's an old trick straight out of the
authoritarian handbook
tell so many lies that people can no
longer tell fact from fiction
his last and most damaging lie was over
and over
he repeated to the american people
they stole the election they rigged the
election
donald trump's apologists will come to
the floor of the senate in the next few
days
and say that he had a first amendment
right to say whatever he wanted
whether it was the truth or not but no
one not even
the president has a first amendment
right to incite an
insurrection against this government
that's not a right it's a crime
a high crime when he first ran for
president
2016 donald trump said the only way he
could lose
is if the election were stolen four
years later he tweeted the lie of the
stone election
so many times at his rallies when he
lost he tried to convince the courts he
went to 60 different
courts pleading that the election had
been rigged and stolen
they laughed him out of the court every
time
he tried to bully officials in swing
states and members of his own
administration
on january 2nd a day as americans were
dying at covet 19.
donald trump was on the telephone to the
republican secretary of state of georgia
spending more than an hour pleading and
threatening him
to somehow find the votes to overturn
that state's votes in the presidential
election
trump failed the republican secretary of
state
refused his request was not intimidated
by his threats
and had the foresight to tape record the
the
conversation so there could be no denial
for weeks before january 6 donald trump
exhorted his followers to come to
washington
on the day that congress would assemble
to certify state electoral votes
he knew that his extremist followers
were waiting for their signals
and their orders over the summer when
armed extremists stormed and occupied
state capitals demanding an end to covet
safety instructions
donald trump cheered him on on january
6th he whipped him into a frenzy
just a few short miles from here he
spoke for more than an
hour on that rally at the ellipse this
is some of what he said
and i quote donald trump to the mob on
its way to the capitol
we will never give up he said we will
never concede it doesn't happen
and then he said we won this election we
won it by a landslide
this was not a close election then he
spoke of his vice president he said
i hope mike is doing the right thing i
hope so
i hope so because if mike pence does the
right thing we win the election
all vice president has to do is send it
back to the states to recertify
and we become president you are the
happiest people
and then he said we have to fight like
hell donald trump said to that crowd
before they committed up to the capitol
if you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore donald
trump said
our exciting adventures and boldest
endeavors have not yet begun
we're going to the capitol we're going
to try and give the republicans the kind
of pride and boldness
they need to take back our country
donald trump wasn't shocked at what
happened next
the crowd followed orders he was excited
according to reports he ignored pleas
from the white house who begged him
people around him begged him to do
something to calm the mob
before they got to the capitol at 2 11
p.m the mob smashed through the doors
and windows began pouring into this
building
13 minutes later while the chat while
the mob chanted hang mike pence
donald trump tweeted mike pence didn't
have the courage to do what should have
been done to protect our
country giving states a chance to
certify a corrected set of facts
the usa demands the truth at 601 pm
donald trump again tweeted to the mob
four hours after they'd broken into this
building
here's what he said these are the things
and events that happen when a sacred
landslide election victory is
unceremoniously and viciously stripped
away
from great patriots who have been badly
and unfairly treated for so long
go home with love and in peace
and he closed remember this day forever
i will those of us in this building at
the moment
will brian sicknick's family will
now narrowly all of our republican
colleagues tell us it's time to move on
forget about it forget the authoritarian
president with his contempt for
democracy
that some of this mob forget the failed
coup without account accountability
just move on polls show that the
majority of republican voters in america
believe
donald trump's lie they still believe
him
even after it's been rejected by local
and state election officials of both
parties
that's why this senate is proceeding to
the second impeachment trial tomorrow
donald trump has gone from elected
office but the poison he injected in the
national bloodstream remains
and grows even more toxic
on the inauguration of president joe
biden
it was different than any i've seen and
it was the tenth one that i witnessed
the crowd was contained in a very small
guarded area
there were many more national guardsmen
on the streets of washington
as he was sworn in on january 20th than
the crowd that
assembled on the mall i used to go to
central america visited countries like
el salvador
i can remember being in the capital of
san salvador
i was struck at the time by soldiers
standing
on the street corners with automatic
weapons and i thought what kind of
country can this be
that soldiers will stand out just like a
normal cop on the beat
with automatic weapons we've reached
that point here in washington
we've reached that point in the senate
chamber
it's a reminder of the fragility and
vulnerability
of our democracy
there's a great cost to what we've just
been through and we continue to
incur it to keep this people people in
this capital safe
and those who visit but there's a deeper
cost
brian sicknick is part of the cost of
january 6.
he was proud to protect this capital and
he gave his life in doing it
last wednesday officer sicknick's ashes
were carried in a wooden box
into the rotunda the capitol where he
laid in honor
the solemnity and hush silence that
greeted his return was made more painful
by memories of how an aggrieved and
angry mob had desecrated
this building that he loved brian
sicknick paid for that hush peace with
his life
he's won in a long line of patriots
who've given their lives over more than
240 years to protect this country
for his sake for all those wounded on
january 6
and for the safety of our democracy we
have to put an
end to donald trump's big lie once and
for all
and look honestly at the culpably the
man
who incited this mob to attack congress
to attack the constitution and to attack
our way of life
i yield the floor
all the role this baldwin
you
madam president the senator from alaska
and president is the senate in a quorum
call it is
ask that the quorum call be initiated
without objection
madam president as many of us know our
country is
mourning the loss of a great man a man
who i believe was one of the greatest
of the greatest generation yesterday we
all received the
sad news that george schultz
secretary schultz
died in his home in california yesterday
he was a hundred years old he celebrated
his hundredth birthday
in december he was a man of great
intelligence
of courage of integrity
exemplified service
was great about this nation and hope for
our country and
not just for our country but countries
around the world
democracy itself was something that this
great american promoted
he leaves behind his wife charlotte
three daughters two sons eleven
grandchildren nine great-grandchildren
of course
our prayers for his family are going out
to all of them during these
during this difficult time madam
president there are people who have
lived history and there are people who
have made
history secretary schultz made
history he lived a life in full
and he was always giving back to his
country to his fellow americans
he was one of only two i believe
uh american citizens who held four
different
cabinet posts in the u.s government
he was omb director secretary labor
secretary of the treasury and
most importantly secretary of state
for almost the entire two terms of
president reagan's
tenure during some very perilous times
in our country's history
as secretary of state there is no doubt
that secretary schultz along with
president reagan
did so much to win the cold war
to bring down the berlin wall eventually
to
successfully not just defeat
in the cold war the soviet union but to
foster the infrastructure of democracy
around
the globe if you read about his
exploits if you read his autobiography
you'll see
so much of what george schultz did
for our country which was so important
it's not an exaggeration to say
we're living in a more peaceful and
prosperous world there's no doubt we
have challenges
because of men like secretary
schultz now one of the great honors of
my lifetime was to get to know
secretary schultz over the last several
years i
had the opportunity to meet with him
many many times
and to listen and learn in his mind was
so
sharp the stories that he would tell
and this to me is another great example
of leadership
people who even in the end years of
their life
are still mentoring others whether
senators or students he would regularly
teach classes out at stanford
as part of the hoover institution out
there he kept writing
books
until his 100th birthday
i had the opportunity to wish him a
happy birthday in december and was even
on a zoom
call with him and i will say in my
experience with him certain things
kept coming out themes of a life service
of course
patriotism integrity
trust and also the united states marine
corps
you know um madam president
when it when it comes to the issue of
integrity you look at
secretary schultz's career his life
and he always had integrity as the
highest principle
and he talked about that not just
integrity to do the right thing
which meant sometimes saying no but he
did this throughout his career and then
at the very twilight of his career he
talked about not just
integrity but trust and trust
as the coin of the realm
of a good life of service
and uh as he was turning 100 in december
he put out a little pamphlet
it's right here i read the whole thing i
encourage my colleagues to read it
life and learning after 100 years
trust is the coin of the realm
reflections on trust and effective
relationships
across a new hinge of history george p
schultz december 13th 2020.
who does that when they're 100 to put
out a pamphlet
on trust well george schultz does that
in the pamphlet secretary schultz wrote
that one lesson he learned as a child
and retained over and over again was the
importance of trust
as he says in this pamphlet when trust
is in the room
whatever room that was the family room
the school room the coaches room
the office room the government room or
the military room
good things happen when trust was not in
the room
good things did not happen and i think
certainly we can learn that here in the
united states senate where trust is the
coin of the realm here
there's no doubt about that this idea of
trust
is a lesson that stayed with him
throughout his career
in a concept that he believes when you
read all his writings and talk to him
the way so many of us have had the
opportunity to
believed helped lead to the end of the
cold war trust
president reagan general secretary
gorbachev together
eliminated intermediate-range nuclear
whip
weapons which laid down the foundation
for the peaceful
end of the cold war in which the united
states was victorious
so madam president at the end of my
remarks i'd like to submit
for the record this pamphlet
by secretary schultz on trust
without objection even to the end of his
days
he was still looking at
providing guidance to to the senate
i had a talk with him as i mentioned
just about
five weeks ago about him coming to
testify
in front of the armed services committee
a tradition started by
another great american john mccain
chairman of the armed services committee
was
every january january we would start
with some statesmen with a lot of
knowledge and history
and george schultz was always part of
that test find in front of the armed
services committee at 98
99 years old with henry kissinger
the junior man in the room who was just
a year or two younger
senator reid and i were just talking
recently about bringing
secretary schultz back to once again
testifying from the armed services
committee
and i'm sad to say we have lost this
great american before he could do that
again
but let me conclude with this madam
president
the other thing i loved about george
schultz
is that he was first and foremost a
united states marine
until the end of his life he spoke about
the pride he gained from serving
in combat in world war ii as a marine
corps officer
and the many many lessons
he learned throughout his life
from his service in the marines first
time i ever met the secretary
went into his office he thought it would
be a bunch of pictures with famous
people there were some of those
but there was marine corps recruiting
posters everywhere
secretary of state former secretary of
state condoleezza rice another great
american
recounts in her excellent op-ed about
the legacy of secretary schultz just
yesterday in the washington post
and he told her that being secretary of
state
was the best job in government
when she got nominated to be secretary
of state he called her to give her some
advice
they were very good friends he was a
mentor of hers as well
he said it's the best job in government
secretary of state and then he corrected
himself
it's the best job except for when i was
a marine corps captain
that's what he told khan so he was first
and foremost a marine
but for all these reasons madam
president
i will be calling up a resolution a
bipartisan resolution
to honor the life achievements and
legacy
of the honorable george
p schultz who has done so much
for our great nation we're working on
this hopefully we'll get it passed in
the senate here soon should
it's very bipartisan already i was
hoping to get it done tonight
but um when great americans leave us
it's really important that we reflect
and look on the life of service
commitment patriotism honor courage and
learn from that
and though even though he's gone after
100 years
i know i'm going to be learning from
george schultz for a long
long time and i sure hope
and i expect and uh
certainly believe that my colleagues
here in the united states senate and our
fellow americans will be as well
i yield the floor
madam president the majority leader i
consent the senate proceed to executive
session to consider the following
nomination
executive calendar number 14 kathleen
holland hicks
of virginia to be deported deputy
secretary of defense without objection
i asked consensus
nomination department of defense
kathleen holland hicks of virginia to be
deputy secretary
i ask consent that the senate vote on
the nomination with no intervening
action or debate that if confirmed the
motion to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table and the
president be immediately notified of the
senate's action
without objection
the question is on confirmation of the
nomination
all those in favor say aye aye
all opposed no the eyes appear to have
it
the eyes do have it the nomination is
confirmed
madam president i ask unanimous consent
that the senate resume legislative
session
without objection uh madam president
i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to the on-block consideration of
the following resolutions that were
submitted earlier today senate res 38
senate res 39 senate res 40 senate res
41.
the clerk will report the resolutions on
block
senate resolution 38 establishing
procedures for access to the floor of
the senate
and the senate wing of the capitol and
so forth
senate resolution 39 to authorize the
installation of appropriate equipment
and furniture in the senate chamber
and so forth senate resolution 40
establishing procedures for access to
the galleries of the senate
chamber and so forth senate resolution
41
allowing limited laptop computer access
on the floor of the senate and so forth
is there objection to proceeding on
block
without objection i ask unanimous
consent the resolutions be agreed to on
block that the motions to cons
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
without objection
so ordered madam president i ask
unanimous consent that when the senate
completes its business today it adjourn
until
one o'clock p.m tuesday february 9th
further that following the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings be
approved to date the time for the two
leaders be reserved for their use later
in the day and morning business be
closed
further that upon conclusion of morning
business the senate resumed the
impeachment trial of former president
donald john
trump is there objection without
objection
if there's no further business to come
before the senate i ask that it stand
adjourned under the previous order
the senate stands adjourned until 1 pm
tomorrow
you